One, two, three, you hear me.
Good afternoon, it's a pleasure to be here
the day, we oar very excited to introduce
a new technology that developed in the past
12 months using JavaScript and some with WiFi
and blue tooth connectivity that allow us
to have the IOT connected with the JavaScript.
I just make a quick introduction about myself,
May name is Frederico, I'm planning a global‑‑
called dog Hunter, the little guys on the
hon train with my two daughters, we have a
global start up based in US‑‑ we build
WiFi modules.
We are here today to explain a little bit
about our Open Sourcability prop named Linieo,
the philosophy behind the Linio project is
basically to bring the hacker community and
the maker community all together.
So we're building a gateway that allow the
hackers that try apps on the web to talk with
the makers community that usually write software
for the real things.
Switch, Light Controllers stuff like that.
What is Linio,.
It's an Open Source project based on an echo
system.
So we build hardware, we build WiFi and blue
tooth modules, we write open software that
allow us to use JavaScript to interact with
micro controller, we write also the open Cloud
software that allows the user to interact
with the Cloud.
We call this project Lin Io, we have Lino.OS,
IO and J S, we call it Linux for IoT.
What we're trying to do is we build a server
module, sever hardware, one of the module
is a Chiwawa, a small lodge yule of Linux
built in, and we built this module in any
devices that has an MCU, so basically we bring
the powerful Linux inside the MCU.
As you can see here, we have full Linux OO
is package manager, WiFi connectivity, and
we build this module inside free scale MCU,
At mel,SM any generic MC um, we transform
the dam devises into something we call smart
devices connected all together with WiFi and
blue tooth.
So, how do we do that? The classic approach
is basically to write code for the MCU and
then to find the library or gateway that allow
the Linux to talk with MCU.
We build something different.
We basically took the MCU directly inside
the Linux part, and then all the features
of the MCU that should be analog devices GPIO,
PWM, SPSPI is part of the Linux part, it's
all together in just one core (SPI, UART‑‑
what we're able to do here is to keep the
MPU for Apache, JavaScript, and OGS and still
use the MCU for the real‑time application.
And, we do that not only on the wireless space
but also‑‑ not only in the wired space,
but also the wireless, any module that is
connected on our network exsport the features
of the Linux OS, and we're able to see all
these features just in the file system.
So, basically, we can control devices, just‑‑
that's a very simple example that I have here,
using switch on or switch off and basically
what happen when I use this devices everything
is on the file system, so I can see the results
of my devices directly in the file system.
The sample that I have here, I can change
the PWM value just changing a value in the
file system, as you can see in the Sys/Class/Mcuio‑‑
I can do the ADP and the GIO in the classical
application you have to write your application
in the MCU, you need to write your application
in the Linux, and then you need to use some
API some bridge to talk together.
With this solution you don't have to do that,
but just to use the file system, so whatever
happened on the MCU would be exported on this
file system here.
So, we build bunch of hardware modules that
have already this technology.
One very famous is that Arduino Yun, we build
this module last September and as you can
see we build basically an MCU from Atmil and
we build the Linux part and we bring it all
together.
We have other modules like something we call
lightening OI, the same stuff we did with
Rrdin Yun‑‑ just a different form factor.
We build also some modules LJ module we call
Chiwawa, it's for mass production, same thing
you can use with Yun other Yun one but a small
module you can bring on your project.
And then we have some other module that are
available today to $2 .4 and 5 gig hearts,
we have a free scale MCU, because very important
part that e with build this technology as
a cross platform technology, so we can use,
basically an ATML MCU, and new MCment that
you are working right now.
And, of course, we also build some shield,
so with the sensor that allow you to control
stuff.
So let me talk a little bit about the software
modules.
And, talk a little bit about open stack and
then show you some sample we did and we are
able to show you in the back stage.
So, basically we have two modules the hardware
that is the Linux part and the MCU part, and
in this sample here we have a Mips Mpu, we
have our Linux up and running, and then we
have the Linio that is another small operating
system that is up and running on MCU, and
we are able to export all features directly
on the file system on the Linux machine, doesn't
matter if the Linux machine is on my desk
or is somewhere else, like Boston, Chicago,
time able to control everything as native
application on my desk.
So, this Linio operating system, we're yourselfing
right now open WRT, and we building top of
that Linio using the Linux card modules and
on top of that we is the NOGS for embedded
development or we can use just the shell scripting
Java, Lua, Python, and of course, on top of
everything, we have the application wrote
in JavaScript for mobile application or Cloud
applications.
To keep simple we build a small ID that runs
directly on the module, you don't need external
application, external tools, you can use our
ID Linio that is built directly inside the
module.
As you can see, you can definitely use no
node JS to write your application as a sever
label.
This is a screen shop of Ideino, we have the
mile manager, everything is Open Source, everything
is available directly inside the module.
We made a couple slides now that we are trying
to show you a real scenario, so the first
is mood Cue basically a node.js software that
we build inside the module, we have several
modules that we bring here, then we made another
demo using mobile control, so basically iPhone,
and everything has been done using JavaScript.
So let's show the first one.
The first one uses one of our module, everything
is Open Source, open hardware, we build open
module, someone else could make it and we
put some little switch that allow us to control
the motor.
The code that you need to write on the node.js
side is the one that you see here, we import
our library, from node.js, we connect to analog
port zero and then we basically use a call
back to set the digital 9 to the very mode.
What happened is when we turn the switch on
and off, we're able to move the RO that show
us our mode.
I'm using a small demo here, I'm using Ideno,
I write my code directly on my computer.
When is done, I start run, and transfer the
control over my little CPU, as you can see,
there is an initiallization procedure, and
then I move the RO directly with the switch.
And is done directly on the board, so I don't
need to use any library, any bridge.
Everything is done inside the JavaScript environment
as I showed you before.
We build another application, a little more
complex that I will be happy to show you in
the back stage, if you want, that basically
control an LED, a very easy one, something
we call the hello world for the MCment.
So, in that case, we made a small application
on HTML 5 using our library, again, an Open
Source library that you can use on the mobile
control, so, in JavaScript and jQuery, what
we build inside the small devise in the lines
of code, we import the Lin eo board, the HTML
board and import the GTO‑‑ we are using
tool in this case, we're using Intel X D K
tool to be able to control over the phone
my device, and the code that I have to write
on these tools is basically what you can see
here.
So, some initiallization code, and then event
when I press the button on my mobile.
And this is the demo.
Again, I'm using any.
deno, inside the board, press the code, press
run, transfer the control, now to my mobile
application that will be able to control my
device.
The one that we're using right now is Lineo,
but we can use Lineo 1, but use any other
module.
It's Open Source, so we can put this code
to any other Linux platform or TP link router
whatever.
The software that you're viewing now is an
Intel X D K that allowstous have an application
from an iPhone in an easy way, we don't need
to apply to put our application in the apple
App store, that's why we use this, it's an
Intel XDK, it was a company that was recently
acquired by Intel.
Very easy stuff.
Now, this is very, very simple application,
you can say, hey, we saw that, many, many
times.
The difference is, I don't need to take care
of the micro controller, the only thing I
need do is write the JavaScript application
that will play with the Java file system.
You can see it on the desk, but it can be
run remotely.
The last part of our software structure is
the Cloud, and that is something that we're
going to announce in the next week in New
York.
And basically we're building a system provisioning
platform that allows us to have control over
the Cloud.
Everything is Open Source, so you can eventually
build your own Cloud to control your hardware.
The provisioning platform, we are working
to build a special MPN library just for Lineo
(NPM) we're using Mips technology now, sometime
we need to recompile the library, in our small
module we don't have the power enough to do
that so we're doing it directly in our serverrers,
we oar working to have an e quo system to
take all the modules and connect it together,
and of course, we're bringing this technology,
also to other devices, Raspberry Pive, BeagleBone,
or call come,‑‑ it is one I don't know
if you're familiar with this (Qualcomm) it
was a very short introduction, I hope you
enjoyed.
I hope if you have any questions, I will be
more than happy to show you in more details
what we've done, and I just want to say thank
you for your time and your patients today.
Thank you so much (Applause)